foreign
[Music]
at the end of the Sky Realm I mean a
wall Maybe
hey can I ask you something
[Music]
foreign
you guys see that ship the Church of
Avia grows Bolder by the day and cannot
sit idly by and allow such Deeds to go
unpunished
[Music]
foreign
's top three said to be the Skydome
strongest
why are you here this has nothing to do
with you
wow I can't imagine captaining a crew at
your age I'm not exactly a slouch myself
make it worth my while Sky Ferris
Captain I'll clear a path stay close
see you there
for the action music
[Music]
let our place
one stroke stream
[Music]
go time no eye Contracting
they can run but they can't fly from the
grand Cypher not while I'm Helmsman
you think you can safely real what a
fool
[Music]
come the Stars await and we mustn't keep
them
Lilith
is enough